In this video,
we'll describe in a bit more detail how
we can use [inaudible] to extract some
features for a given problem.
So one of the most popular,
uh,
usage of sparks coding is
to extract features that is,
say we want to perform a particular
classification problem. Uh,
and we would lie to use our
data and find a representation,
the new representation for our data,
which is going to make the problem
with classification easier.
So a specifically imagine I have
some label training set where I have,
uh, some inputs and each input
is associated to the class label.
So imagine say that the inputs are a
set of images and yt is the class of the
image. Well, to extract some
feature, what we could do is, uh,
we could first train is parse
coding dictionary on the data set.
That only consists of the inputs.
So we've thrown away for now
temporarily the labels yt.
So if we run our sparse coding or a
dictionary learning algorithm on that
Dataset, this will give us
a dictionary matrix deep.
And from that dictionary Matrix,
well,
I could then take all of my inputs
and compute what's the sparse later in
representation, uh, based
on this learn dictionary.
And now what I could do is just take my
original dataset and change it in a way
where I'll remove the original input
and I'll replace it by the sparse
representation.
And so now for any classifier,
I can just use my favorite class fire,
whether it's a neural network or a support
vector machine or a decision tree or
any costs of fire.
I can't just train it on the new dataset
where I've replaced the input by its
parts coding representation.
And from it,
I now have to predict again the label,
but now I have to predict it,
uh, from the, uh,
extracted features from the sparse
representation. And I've, uh,
I had, uh, my system was
confronted with a new input x.
Well then the process of classifying it
would correspond to first inferring it's
parsed coding representation,
h of x,
and then I would feed it to
require to my classifier that I've,
that I've trained here.
So while this part gives me a d matrix,
this parts gives me a classifiers,
say h a f of uh,
of my input.
But now the input that I have to give
it for my cost fire f is actually a spar
squirting representation h of x much like,
and that's because it was trained on
these types of features. Okay. Now,
uh,
for this to be meaningful to make sense,
you essentially have to believe that uh,
these parts coding representation
is going to make the problem easier.
That is my data is such that it's a,
there is a sparse representation which
will identify features that are more
directly related to what's the
class label associated with my data.
So one such type of data is a image
data and in particular let's consider a
image data that corresponds
to handwritten digits.
So I have a very small image
and in the image I have a,
a Henredon wreck characters. So this would
be an image that would be labeled too.
So I have one that would be
one, uh, a pair of example, uh,
with which my, uh, one, the train
my learning of them. Well, uh,
if I run sparse coding on a bunch
of handwritten digits images,
uh,
so I would just scrap temporarily while
I'm running my smart scoring algorithm,
the label and just run on
the images itself. Well,
we have an illustration here,
the types of features we would get.
So now each lil square here,
so that's a square,
that's another square,
that's another square and
so on is a visualization of
one atom in my dictionary.
You Matrix one column,
so I can visualize it because each Adam,
uh,
is a vector of size.
Number of inputs is the same
size as the input size and a,
and because the input is an image,
then I can just reshape my vector
also into the shape of an image.
And then individualization,
if the pixel is great,
it means that the value of the vector
for that Pixel is zero. If it's white,
then it's positive and it's black,
it's negative.
So this essentially
corresponds to, uh, uh, the,
uh,
sort of illustrative,
a visualization of what each
sparse code element, uh, and coats.
So if I,
in my responsibility in representation,
the code associated say with that
feature had the large positive value.
So if this was, uh, uh,
the first feature though,
so x if h of x one was a,
because this will be the first feature,
if it had a large value,
it would mean that if I was to
reconstruct the original input,
I would add one times this little limit
here and say if this would be the other
image, then I add also
this part and so on. Okay.
So that's why this is a meaningful
visualization of the representation.
And now we see that each spar
scope actually has learned, uh,
what looks like essentially
a bunch of pen strokes.
So this will be a pen stroke like this.
This would be a pen stroke like that.
And this one will be like this.
So essentially PowerSchool as parsing
representation would be a big vector that
identifies,
which are this,
the different pen strokes that are
present in some given image. And,
uh,
in fact,
if we were to ask someone to describe
the problem of classifying digits,
uh,
enter the digits,
then it would probably actually use a
description that's based on pen strokes.
So to describe it too, I might say, well,
it has a sort of a bar on as a
loop at the bottom and so on.
So we can see that, uh, intuitively,
this seems to make sense.
This would be a nice way of representing
digit that makes the class information
much more obvious than just
the raw value of the pixels.
So this is why for image data and this
particular case and with the digits
sparse coding features
work well in practice.
In fact,
we could actually train our [inaudible]
coding dictionary on the different type
of data set.
Uh,
so if we had a large collection of
unlabeled images that did not exactly
correspond to the type of images
we wanted to classify a test time,
we could still use the unlabeled images
to extract a better representation and
see whether it transfers
to, uh, uh, are, uh,
my main important problem that,
uh,
I actually want to solve
in terms of classification.
So this is actually known
as self taught learning. Uh,
so it's a combination of unsupervised
learning and transfer learning, uh,
for those that know more
about machine learning.
So these are unsupervised and transfer
learning how to well known types of, uh,
of learning and a self taught learning
can be seen as a combination of both.
So a in south thought learning,
the idea is that we want to train
some features but on a different input
distribution,
uh,
because we might have more data from
that input distribution than the
distribution, uh, for which we actually
want to solve a particular, say,
a classification problem.
So there's a concrete example.
Imagine I had a lot of enrooted digits,
a lot of images of handwritten digits,
and that those were actually not labeled.
I didn't know the no humans
went over the images,
actually specify the label
for each image. And, uh,
and now imagine that what I really want
to do actually is classify a handwritten
English characters.
So alphabetical characters and not
numerous numerical characters and uh,
but imagine that actually have
very little training data for that.
And now can we still try to improve
things by leveraging my unlabeled data,
even though it's, it's a different input
distribution. So they're not, uh, uh,
these are numeric characters and these
are, uh, alphabetical characters.
So you're going to look quite different.
And also they might come from,
from different people that
actually drew them. So, uh,
so here's the experiment, uh, taken
from this paper by a reign of battle,
the packer and Ang. Uh, so,
uh, they're the authors,
the researchers that introduced
the notion of self taught learning.
So in this experiment,
they did exactly what I described.
They are,
took a lot of unlabeled digit,
a character's Hendrickson characters,
uh,
and they trained a idea
or did nothing with it,
so they didn't use it to extract a
feature representation or they trained a
linear PCA representation
from the digits data,
or they train these parts
coding representation.
So they train the dictionary matrix
from which they could extract these past
representation.
And now they use these features to
classify a Hendra did English and written
characters. So, uh,
alphabetical characters.
And so what we have here is the,
uh,
performance for different
training sets, sizes, uh,
in the, uh, label Dataset.
So we see that these data psychically
fairly small in this case. So, uh,
we can hope that we can leverage the
information in the large unlabeled data.
And, uh, so we have the performance
if we use no feature representation.
So we just use the, uh, the x t, uh,
raw representation or
the PCA representation,
or does parts coding representation
as learned on the, uh, difference,
uh, data on the digits data. And what
we see is that using some sparse coding,
uh,
we often see an increase in the
courtesy for a 500 and a thousand.
In this particular experiment,
we saw better performance,
better accuracy than if
I'd use the raw original,
a representation,
or even that,
just a PCA representation and a for a
hundred in this particular experiment that
the performance was almost the
same as, uh, if I've used the, uh,
uh, the raw representation. So
we didn't lose much really here.
So this is another illustration that
sparks coding features can be useful for
performing classification as a,
if we use that as in a sense of
preprocessing step for a, uh,
our favorite a classifier.